in this lesson we're going to do some
electrophilic aromatic substitution
practice problems I'll teach you to
evaluate directing effects of groups
present on the ring and evaluate the
groups that you're introducing are they
activating or deactivating to get the
most viable synthesis possible I'm also
going to introduce you to a couple new
reactions here that'll help you cope
when you see these types of problems
let's begin with this example I'm going
to redraw the molecule so that we can
look at directing effects now I've
colored each of these groups and now we
want to evaluate where that group would
put something else on the ring so we can
see if we can decide which group to
install first let's begin by evaluating
chlorine inductively this is an electron
withdrawing group however chlorine has
three lone pairs of electrons that by
resonance it can donate into the ring
this effect wins resonance often wins
over inductive effects and so we're
gonna get an ortho/para director here
I'm going to put some asterisks on the
ring to show this so chlorine will
direct to these three starred positions
now let's evaluate the sulphonic acid
this is a very electron withdrawing
group and it is going to direct meta to
itself okay so if we look at where we've
starred this structure we can see that
chlorine will put the sulphonic acid
group across from it it might have some
mixture of ortho isomers but this will
direct this here so this evaluation is
telling us that it'll make sense to put
on the chlorine first then introduce all
sulphonic acid this is also a good idea
for another reason the chlorine is a
moderately deactivating group so it
pulls electron density out of the
aromatic ring and makes it less likely
to react as a nucleophile which we need
for electrophilic aromatic substitution
but the sulphonic acid is strongly
deactivating so once it's on there it's
quite hard for the ring to react so it's
really good we have a very great
situation set up where we can introduce
our moderately
activating group first then add in our
sulphonic acid and make the molecule we
want I'm going to show this
retrosynthetic Li just to give you a
little practice with thinking backwards
as well we said due to the directing
effect of chlorine we want to introduce
the sulphonic acid last so we're going
to disconnect that first we'll show a
wavy line to represent that when we
break this bond we'll get back to
chlorobenzene
and in each of these problems I'm gonna
want you to take it back to benzene just
for the practice I'm sure there's better
commercially available molecules we
could buy but we'll go back to benzene
so so we'll show one more arrow that
Cleaves the chlorine off of the ring
great we have a synthetic plan let's
show our forward synthesis to effect
chlorination we can treat benzene with
chlorine in the presence of iron tri
chloride
now our ortho para director is installed
on the ring and we can do sulfonation
now this deactivates the ring so I think
that we should use fuming sulfuric acid
which is sulfur trioxide in h2 so4
that'll give it a little kick so3 is a
better electrophile and so we can get
this reaction to go even though the ring
is a bit deactivated
now since chlorine is an ortho para
director we might get a mixture of ortho
and para products the para product often
dominates it's kind of hard to put a
group ortho because of steric hindrance
so we'll get mostly this product so this
is a good reaction but we might want to
acknowledge if our professor asks us to
draw all products we might want to
acknowledge that we will form some of
this and I'm just going to box the
product that we want now one thing I
haven't mentioned to you yet is that the
sulphonation reaction is actually
reversible so if we take these products
and warm them up in sulfuric acid we can
get this group to leave and so in this
case it was great we put it in the
position that we wanted to predominantly
because this para product forms more
readily however in some cases we might
be able to install this group to control
react
and then remove it later let's try an
example to see if we can apply this new
information let's redraw our molecule
with some color so we can do our
evaluation of the groups again we have a
halogen I've just colored it green again
this is going to direct ortho para to
itself hey and that looks pretty good
that's where we need an OHA and our
hydroxyl group is also going to direct
ortho para to itself okay that directs
where we need the bromine so we have a
really good situation set up here but we
need to figure out what to introduce
first let's think about how activating
and deactivating these groups are then
this OAH group is strongly activating
and the bromine like the chlorine is
moderately deactivating so we have our
first activating group in this problem
the activating group has electrons that
have great resonance with the ring so we
get a lot of electron density in the
ring and so these positions are quite
activated for attack in fact with
phenols apero position undergoes EA s
quite readily so we almost have like a
double star here where it's really
directing to this position well that's
kind of tough because we do want to
introduce this first but it's going to
want to direct here since this is our
strong activator we definitely want to
introduce it first because it makes the
ring able to attack things better
however we will get a regio selectivity
problem because the bromine will want to
go here see if you can think of a way to
use our blocking group and remove it
starting with maybe Fionn all go ahead
and pause me and try that okay we'll
jump right into the forward synthesis
and I'm going to show you how to make
phenol from benzene if we're starting
with benzene we could nitrate reduce and
go through a die a so compound to add in
water and and get our phenol but there's
a more straightforward way so first we
can brominate this gives bromo benzene
and then if we treat this with sodium
hydroxide and heat it up really really
hot we can get Fionn all that
way so double Delta lots and lots of
heat this is actually a benzene reaction
and so let me show you the mechanism of
that really quickly so we have bromine
with the adjacent H atom the inductive
electron withdrawing effect of bromine
helps with the acidity of these adjacent
protons and NaOH can actually
deprotonate this under these very
forcing conditions let's show the arrow
pushing hydroxide will deprotonate here
these electrons will push in and we'll
kick off bromine this gives us a benzine
which absolutely exists though it looks
like it shouldn't we have this triple
bond in an aromatic ring and triple
bonds really want to be linear so this
is a very very reactive compound excess
hydroxide in the solution can now come
in and act as a nucleophile and for our
arrow pushing will get
attack at either carbon pushing the
electrons on to the adjacent carbon and
to finish off this mechanism we just
need to show this getting protonated
with water and our arrow pushing will
look like this so now that we have fun
all it's really going to want to react
at this para position so let's do that
let's sulfonate it at that para position
if you watch my sulfonation video you'll
know that there's these two ways to do
this Fionn all being so activated should
smoothly react in EAS being becoming
sulphonated with just h2 so4
now we've blocked this position and
we've blocked with a group that's going
to direct meta
oh well that's convenient our Oh H can
now only direct to it's ortho positions
and this one is directing meta and
that's the same position and it's where
we want our bromine so this is a really
nice work around to avoid regio isomeric
mixtures
let's Broman eight now now we can warm
this molecule in dilute
and remove our blocking group this gives
our target molecule with good
regioselectivity
now let's try a little bit more
challenging of an example here is the
molecule we want to make from benzene
let's evaluate our directing effects NH
2 is a strong activator that directs
ortho and para to itself and the methyl
group is a weak activator that directs
ortho and para so you can see the
challenge neither of these groups are
directing where we want so we have to
consider groups that might be able to be
converted into these groups that give
other directing effects let me show you
a couple reactions you might be able to
use and then we'll try our synthesis so
here's a couple reactions that might be
useful nitro groups can be reduced to
amines nitro is a meta director that can
be reduced to an amine by treatment with
lithium aluminum hydride hydrogenation
and sometimes some other reductive
conditions we also can convert carbonyl
compounds so aldehydes or ketones can be
converted to the methyl group via the
wolf kishna reduction or the Clemmensen
reduction this is also a meta director
that's being converted to an ortho para
director here so we have some options
why don't you pause me and see if you
might be able to come up with a
synthesis on your own okay now we need
to figure out which of these routes we
should actually apply well nitro is a
really deactivating group so if we
imagine will have a nitro and introduce
a ch3 well we're talking friedel-crafts
chemistry and with nitro benzene neither
friedel-crafts alkylation nor isolation
is very good they do not work on this
compound
so maybe the nitration isn't going to be
our best way to go now the carbonyl
compound this is deactivating but not as
strongly as this positively charged
nitrogen containing nitro group here so
this might be our best way to go
you'll recall that ketones are formed
smoothly by friedel-crafts isolation
using the corresponding acid chloride
however to introduce this aldehyde on
the ring is not quite as straightforward
we can't just use the acid chloride of
the aldehyde because that compound is
too unstable and so we need to use a
reaction called the gather Minh coach
reaction treating benzene with carbon
monoxide gas in the presence of HCl will
give our aldehyde this actually does
form the acid chloride we want but in
the reaction flask where it can be
quickly trapped so we can't buy this
reagent but we can generate it in situ
let me show you that reagent so we'll
generate this from these reagents and
they'll react with benzene forming our
aldehyde now we have a meta director
installed and the only way we really
know to get nitrogen onto the ring
directly is by forming the nitro
compound and then reducing it so now
let's nitrate so we want to remove this
completely from the molecule so we
should think wolf kishna reduction or
Clemmensen reduction and I found some
precedent for using Wolfe Kirchner
conditions to reduce this and also
reducing the nitro group at the same
time so that's convenient we can treat
this with hydrazine in base heat it and
affect the reduction of both of our
groups so we've come up with a nice
chemo selective way to introduce these
two electron donating ortho/para
directing groups in just a few steps and
we introduced a new reaction let's do a
final example this time with three
groups on the ring okay here's our
target molecule let's redraw this and
evaluate the directing effects of the
three groups the ethyl is weakly
activating the bromide is going to be
weakly deactivating and the nitro
strongly deactivating so it would make
sense if we could get this activating
group on first to start introducing our
substituents let's look at directing
effects the ethyl group directs ortho
para the
Romine also directs ortho/para to itself
and finally the Nitro group directs meta
so the way I've placed these stars on
our molecule tells us quite a lot now if
we look the bromide is doubly directed
by this alkyl group and the Nitro group
everything else either has one star and
this has two stars and it's a position
we don't even want substituted at all
so we know it makes sense to get our
activating group on first and then we
know the Nitro will direct the bromine
to the correct spot but the bromine
won't direct the Nitro to the correct
spot so basically our order of events
has been decided for us we need to get
our alkyl on nitrate the compound and
then brahminy so the bromine is directed
well by these two other substituents
being there so let's disconnect that
first that gets us to this alkylated
nitro and we remember we wanted to
introduce this alkyl group first so that
the Nitro would go ortho para and the
ring would be activated so we'll cleave
this nitro off the molecule next that
gives us this molecule with the ethyl
group we might be tempted to put that on
by friedel-crafts alkylation but if we
do this compound will become even more
reactive due to the electron donating
alkyl group anon there and over
alkylation is a problem so as our
solution we can do friedel-crafts
isolation and then reduce the acyl group
that we form introducing an acyl group
deactivates the ring to further attack
and prevents these issues that we have
with friedel-crafts alkylation so we
actually want to take this one step back
to a carbonyl compound okay let's take a
look at our forward synthesis beginning
with benzene we can treat this with an
acid chloride in the presence of
aluminum trichloride now we need to
reduce this to get to the ethyl compound
so we get the correct directing effect
we use the wolf Kitchener last time
let's use the Clemmensen reduction this
time now we can nitrate our compound as
we did in the previous example and
finally we can brominate this in this
less
and we learn to evaluate the directing
effects of different groups on an
aromatic compound we explored a little
bit the deactivating and activating
effects of different groups and learn
that it's best to introduce your
activating groups first if possible we
learned a new reaction for acyl ating an
aromatic ring to give this aldehyde and
we learned how to use a blocking group
when we won't favored addition to the
correct position and sulfonation is a
great reversible reaction that allows us
to block positions on aromatic rings KP
here if you learn something give me a
thumbs up on the way out and for more
chemistry subscribe to my channel